you know sometimes people say Big Pharma
to talk about a gigantic industry which
lobbies are politicians heavily well
I've got a new word for you guys today
big pyramid aka the direct selling
multi-level marketing network marketing
industry poor little lost sheep most of
you have no idea how much money these
guys have and how much they spend to
keep poor people under their thumb which
is why I seen your 100k I'm here to
illuminate the seedy underbelly of big
pyramid and explain how they bought our
politicians on both sides of the aisle
let me say right up front I know I know
I'm aware politics is right now how do I
say it a touchy subject
in fact there's probably not a better
way to divide my audience than if I said
that address is gold and white or the
sound is Laurel mmm but rather than
focusing on disagreements let me remind
you guys of something we can all agree
on
people who relentlessly seek powers suck
I don't care if your left and right
can't we all agree on that basic truth I
I know you know your local politician
probably cares sure but by the time you
get to the tippity tappity tippity-top
you're dealing with people who have
kicked and clawed their way to power by
any means necessary so leave your
partisan politics at the door we're
dealing strictly with power today which
both sides love oh and they love money
too I think we can all agree on that
even socialists need third houses so
with that little intro let me ask you a
basic question why isn't multi-level
marketing illegal we know pyramid
schemes have long been illegal in the
United States so why isn't multi-level
marketing as well in the modern
vernacular the words pyramid scheme and
multi-level marketing are almost
interchangeable for most people we have
clips for days of senior level MLM are
admitting that the opportunity is a
gigantic bait and switch that enriches
the people at the top we sell people on
a dream business that they can make it
yet deep down inside what do we really
know yeah we know that the reality is
that most of them aren't going to make
it that admission would be comical if it
weren't so horrifying I know what I love
about this clip is that you basically
could give this line to the sociopathic
killer Patrick Bateman and
movie American Psycho and it wouldn't
sound out of place at all in the limbs
sell people on a dream knowing most
people won't make it it's actually
insane who wants to bring their family
into a struggle to make it who wants to
bring their family into an eventual
deception this guy is like a little
Bateman in the making and I think he's
actually the perfect symbolic
representation of big pyramid our little
Bateman here because he's following
their playbook to a tee it's a two-faced
industry they say one thing to you
the buyer the guy at the bottom of the
pyramid and the total opposite to the
people at the top you know there's some
people that if they heard that we were
talking like this in a room you know I
would have to have a bulletproof vest on
right now you know what I mean a
bulletproof vest there's only one reason
you need a bulletproof vest
it's if you ruin someone's life and they
literally want to kill you so how is it
that even with plenty of evidence video
evidence big pyramid has stayed legal
even while their little brother the
pyramid scheme has become illegal well
it's because little Bateman and the 3d
triangle have bought our politicians on
both sides of the aisle and that's what
we're going to talk about today the
history of multi-level marketing buying
out our politicians and the Federal
Trade Commission and we're going to
start this conversation by talking about
one of the oldest MLMs in the fight for
the right to pyramid anway owned by
Richard DeVos Richard DeVos is a smart
man who learned in the 1970s that if
Amway was gonna stay alive they'd need
some serious political power to keep
themselves from being regulated and so
began the buyout of the Republican Party
with massive donations from the DeVos
family their incredible influence over
the Republican Party can be best
expressed by a hilarious admission by
Betsy DeVos I quote here my family is
the single largest contributor of soft
money to the National Republican Party I
have decided however to stop taking
offense at the suggestion that we are
buying influence now I simply concede
the point they are right we do expect
some things in return
they've gotten to the point they don't
care anymore it's an open secret they're
just going to come out in a minute now
of course they're buying off the
Republican Party and one of these
so-called expectations that they have is
of course that the Federal Trade
Commission doesn't turn around and shut
down big pyramid and thereby shut down
my now how does this happen
in practice obviously Amway doesn't
literally control everybody in the
government but they do have sway over
the president and the president's choose
the Chairman and nominates the
commissioners of the Federal Trade
Commission this basic fact means that if
you have influence over the president
you by proxy have influence over the
Federal Trade Commission the exact body
of government that is supposed to be
regulating you here's a concrete example
of how this works in 2000 George Bush
appointed Timothy Morris as the FTC
chairman and who was Timothy MERS before
chairman an attorney whose largest
clients included none other than Amway's
so in essence a guy who was protecting
Amway from regulation now became the guy
who was supposed to be regulating them
and Amway and Bush's relationship was
far more than merely financial they were
friends in fact Bush actually spoke at
Rich DeVos his funeral where he extolled
the virtues of Amway here was the
overwhelming evidence of the power of
free enterprise what today is the Amway
World Headquarters
now of course when he's talking about
the virtue of free enterprise you have
to imagine part of that free enterprise
may be the ability to buy protection
from regulation from senior officials in
the government but we have to remember
Republicans aren't always an office and
big pyramid would of course never risk
getting caught off guard during the
wrong four to eight years political
swing and therefore get regulated so
what do they do if they already have the
Republicans in their pockets well they
pay the other party too
Bill Clinton was paid seven hundred
thousand dollars to do a single speech
at an Amway event in Japan a lot of you
know that my Japan's corporate social
responsibility agenda includes is it
just me or is it a little weird that
this guy's been paid $700,000 to
essentially read off a sheet in front of
them can you get any more transparent
that you're paying for political favors
and way Japan's corporate social
responsibility agenda includes
building community houses I cannot stand
this hiring a guy to give a speech in
English in a foreign country basically
just reading off a page hey Amway is a
great company they say look I know what
this is
hey I've done this before it's called a
paid sponsorship except in this case he
doesn't have to disclose it right he
doesn't have to disclose it if I get
paid by audible or Squarespace I have to
disclose it right I have to tell you
guys I've been paid to say this
Bill Clinton gets paid seven hundred
thousand dollars to fly to Tokyo or
Japan or wherever then he could just say
this whatever he wants reads off his
little sponsorship sheet I know this
game not only Clinton though but
Madeleine Albright Secretary of State
under Clinton also took money from big
pyramid ten million dollars over six
years to be brand ambassador for
Herbalife well first of all you have a
great product that makes all the
difference
we got sorry buddy you're a product to
the product well I am a product did
anyone catch that we're the guys like
hey we're paying you ten million dollars
lady you got to say it right you have a
great product no no say our slogan
you're a product of the product
Madeleine Albright right well first of
all you have a great product that makes
all the difference
we got sorry buddy you're a product to
the product watch or try to correct
yourself well I was very impressed truly
impressed it truly impressed get real
guys get real I say you have to disclose
when you're getting paid ten million
dollars when you're gonna chill some
product this is messed up how come they
can make ten million I can't even make a
few thousand bucks without out saying
hey guys hey hey whoa whoa guys careful
careful don't buy this without knowing
that I was fully paid for this interview
and it affected my decision of course it
did to say what I'm gonna say about the
product Madeleine Albright makes ten
million bucks
she can't even pull off that sponsorship
read guys I could have done this babe
look maybe I'd take back everything I
said about Herbalife maybe I should
become a part of big pyramid I don't
know anyways on with the show I just had
to point that out but pressing forward
we find even more ties Jon Leibowitz who
was appointed by Obama as the FTC
Chairman after his appointment ended
also went to Herbalife to serve as in a
senior adviser
so after he works for the Federal Trade
Commission as chairman he goes to
Herbalife you get that you get the
revolving door that's going on here
Obama points of Chairman goes to
Herbalife to serve as senior advisor aka
Daddy Warbucks wants his money after
helping Shake Shack okay if I need to
break it down third grade level that's
just what it is and to bring us now to
present times now we've got old
Trumpster who's massively tied in with
all the MLMs from the beginning we have
Trump Network the Trump Network offers
people the opportunity to achieve their
American dream I'm sure looking for
dreams I'm doing damn well in life but
I'm still looking for the dream and also
ACN a separate MLM that he endorsed
where he reportedly got paid millions
just to endorse them and speak leading
to yet another presidency where big
pyramid gets away with everything and
nothing is done and obviously the Amway
influence hasn't waned at all either
with Betsy DeVos becoming a political
player now as the Secretary of Education
let me just say right off the bat she
didn't get picked because of her SAT
scores and what's my point with all of
us obviously both parties are complicit
big pyramid money runs through the very
heart of our political institutions and
it's going to keep going like this until
enough people have the balls to stand up
and say enough is enough and I say
people plural because it takes more than
one rich dude with an ax to grind to do
it we already all saw Bill Ackman try
and fail and any time a billionaire
fails at anything you know that there
are some serious players at the other
end of the table
what is encouraging though is that word
is out big pyramid is no longer fighting
the battle for public opinion they've
already lost that huge subreddits like
anti MLM and massive videos like the
piece that John Oliver put out I've
really exposed this industry for what it
is
predatory what is left to do however is
call it this incestuous relationship
between MLM and the Federal Trade
Commission brought to you by big doe no
money baby we got to make it stop that's
all I basically wanted to say all that's
left to do now is say that you should go
read Robert Fitzpatrick's report on MLM
x' which i've kind of summarized here
Robert Fitzpatrick is a leading expert
on MLM Xand a renowned critic I
interviewed during my first
investigation into MLM John coffee break
if you want to find out more on the
subject just read his stuff it's
great a link is relevant report on this
below that's all for now I'll see you in
the next one and as always don't forget
to smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
Sakura